[Music]  the best of the best left their hearts  on the dance floor Tuesday night  competing for a chance at 1 million  dollars during night 2 of the world of  dance auditions  here's 23 year-old hopeful fiction the  emotional routine earned a standing  ovation from the judges fiction opened  up about the pain behind his performance  my parents have always been separated  and you know as I keep to have your mom  thousand miles away and your dad that  some miles away apart it's tough she's  tough for a kid mm I get it and get it  the emotional number earned rave reviews  and scored fiction a place in the next  round of competition ET sat down with  the world of dance judges in January  JLo explained why she tends to get a bit  weepy during the show I mean listen  you're talking about kids you know going  for their dreams putting themselves out  there in front of people they get  emotional they feel the pressure they  feel the nerves I know what that feels  like  [Music]  you